have you seen the ending sad it's all a
little sad Jamie Lee Curtis is at the
heart of the Halloween movies and she's
so passionate about them she'd smash her
face into glass so today in honor of
Jamie we're taking a look at what was up
behind the scenes of Halloween ends or
BTS as the kids call them number one
we'd be more than willing to attempt to
kick or punch but not this definitely
not this eyes glass just think about it
Jamie Lee Curtis was adamant she was
doing her own stunt which required
smashing her face into a prop glass
cabinet just because it's a prop doesn't
mean it isn't still dangerous director
David Gordon green said I was reluctant
if not trying to forbid it but it
happened jlc's double only did two shots
in the final battle green revealed that
Curtis said I want him to grab me by the
hair and smash me into the glass and he
was thinking I still got two more weeks
to work with with you I can't have
shards of glass in your face but she did
it that's her face going in the glass
that stunt was her idea number two the
set they built for Michael Myers
neighborhood is freaking huge this is
crazy I've never seen anything like this
an entire neighborhood you can just roam
around imagine what other spooky
monsters lurk there immersive you walk
in the sit every day and feel a little
terrified that you're walking into
Michael Myers house originally they were
just going to rebuild the house in some
neighborhood very aggressive violent
screaming scenes I don't think that's
going to go over well so it ended up on
a stage but it's the most authentic
stage if you ask us because they planted
real trees who wants to move in number
three maybe they need to do just one
more movie so there's no lingering bad
luck this franchise is wrapping up after
13 movies with a lot of tears but what I
didn't really know was what it was going
to feel like hard to anticipate these
crocodile tears for a horror film I'll
miss you we'll miss you too Lori uh we
mean Jamie please keep making movies
I've been playing Lori Strode for 44
years on and off of course but still
it's a lot her last day was intense too
everybody knew was my last day and the
entire crew was there and all the actors
showed up no it's too much now we're
gonna cry ending a professional
relationship that's the most important
one of your life is is powerful number
four don't underestimate the power of
good tree sculpting I enjoy even what
could be the boring part which is just
copying what already exists when you're
working on sequels almost inevitably
there's going to be a bit of recreation
whether that's a performance or a tree
we hired this awesome sculptor number
five kissing the most terrifying moment
of filming at least for the boom op did
they really need to have the mic
recording all this we all know those
sounds are replaced in post with little
hand kisses because wow do they sound
super awkward number six a lot of the
time women in horror films can fall into
the Damsel in Distress trope but jlc has
been pushing back against that with this
movie and to some degree the entire
franchise about social issues about
looking at who we are in the Zeitgeist
of this moment and this time in history
through a slasher film when it came to
the first movie back in 1978 Curtis
already loved the strength of Lori I
just remember being impressed with her
Ingenuity number seven wigs don't always
need to be fancy you know jlc likes her
hair cut short so if you thought that
was her real hair when did you think she
had time to grow that number eight
technology was supposed to make life
easier why then do movies take longer to
film now pure laziness just kidding the
original Halloween movie was made in 17
days Halloween ends was definitely a
longer process the kitchen scene alone
was so intense that it took about a week
initial filming for the final movie took
roughly three months with additional
photography shot months later if you
count the pandemic putting everything on
hold this movie took years to make
number nine talk about a deep connection
with this next one sometimes you can
become so ingrained in a character you
can adopt their musculature we guess
Jamie Lee Curtis said when we broke for
lunch I went into my trailer and my face
hurt I couldn't figure out why my face
hurt and then I realized it was because
Lori smiled Jamie Smiles all the time by
the way but I was in the Lorry mode and
Lori doesn't smile that's when I
realized oh there is the possibility of
Hope number 10. team Lori or team
Michael we're making t-shirts jlc had
only one request when it came to the
kitchen fight please don't make it look
like a movie fight we've all seen the
cliche kitchen fights before this has to
be like a street brawl with no bells and
whistles this needs to be brutal and not
fancy Curtis and James Jude Courtney did
a walk through of the scene before
filming so they could share their own
ideas and suggestions for how to make
the scene actually work number 11 the
kitchen is the most dangerous room in
the house jlcu just wants you to know
that the garbage disposal was her idea
because that's so real have you ever
used a garbage disposal we would rather
fight with anything but the kitchen sink
thank you number 12. the goal for the
trilogy was simple 2018's Halloween was
to restore the trust that fans had lost
in the franchise as well as bring in new
fans Halloween kills was to have fun
with the initial success and open it up
to the chaos and kind of fun house ride
sensation and finally in Halloween ends
they felt they needed to put their own
passionate signatures on top of the
characters it has not only been a
storytelling Evolution but artistic
Freedom has emerged from it too
everything wrong and then it becomes
fight to the end number 13 Jamie Lee
Curtis is a legend for a reason she
brings 100 fight scene to a dramatic
scene to a scream scene
hopefully she's protecting her voice
when she does it the recovery process is
a nightmare when you're on a schedule I
remember exactly how I felt when I was
19 years old I've never screamed once in
my life not once not even into a pillow
not even while running away from your
BFF while playing a game of tag dang
number 14 we don't think anyone actually
stole anything but there are some fans
out there who'd love to get their hands
on a mask James Jude Courtney has kept
all three masks costumes and Prosthetics
he wore on set locked up in a vault to
keep them safe Jaime doesn't steal but
she was gifted a hospital bracelet that
says Lori Strode Haddonfield Memorial
Hospital and director green has also
taken masks and knives and hung them up
in his office saying my office is
protected by four different Michael
Myers and a little bit of his Cutlery
cutlery
number 15. it's hard to picture Jamie's
reaction when she found out she signed
on for a lot more than one movie when
David called me I immediately said yes
when she came on board nobody said
anything about a Trilogy though like the
good sport she is she did all three of
course because she loves these movies
her favorite Parts being the fans and
her character Lori I can't do what I do
without audiences and they can't enjoy a
movie without us bringing them a movie
wow who would have thought you could get
so emotional over a scary movie
certainly not us are you sad it's all
coming to an end let us know in the
comments and thanks for
trick-or-treating with us here at the
things